es war ein unglück das vom himmel kam
das ganze landstriche unter wasser
setzte das zerstörung leid und tod
brachte starkregen bis zu 200 liter pro
quadratmeter überflutete im juli den
kreis ahrweiler
so auch das haus von katrin dapd
wir waren zum glück in der nacht nicht
da wo es passiert ist
wir sind froh dass wir das nicht live
miterleben mussten das war auch danach
die tage schlimm genug dass alles zu
sehen
am 14 juli brach die flut mit voller
wucht durch den ort und zerstörte das
traum häuschen der 40-jährigen
grafikdesignerin im august 2020 haben
wir das häuschen gekauft von einem
freund von mir
wir haben angefangen es zu renovieren
richtig zu machen jedes wochenende jeden
urlaub waren wir hier und haben selber
dran gearbeitet
ja und dann kam ein knappes jahr später
die flut und nun es ziemlich alles weg
in dem knapp 200 jahre alten
fachwerkhaus stand das wasser bis unter
die decke böden wände electric das
inventar und viele persönliche dinge
waren durch wasser und den
kontaminierten schlamm nicht mehr zu
retten das war ein gut vierwöchiges
bootcamp für körper und seele
[Musik]
weil ich manchmal und jetzt war es aber
so viel es wird alles weggeworfen
das ich habe die ersten tage wochen habe
ich habe ich gar nicht geweint weil es
einfach viel zu viel waren weil es
überhaupt nicht greifbar war nur selten
konnte sie sich in den letzten wochen
eine pause von dem zerstörten zu hause
und den schrecklichen bildern können wir
haben tatsächlich wieder fließend wasser
was von großer luxus ist aber war das
wasser noch nicht die heizkörper ist weg
heizungsanlage svec also das wird jetzt
erstmal ein kalter winter und wann es
wieder strom gibt ist noch gar nicht
abzusehen
nun fängt katrin deb gar noch mal von
vorne an ihren traum vom eigenheim zu
erfüllen denn eins hat sie sich
geschworen sie lässt sich von der flut
nicht unterkriegen wir haben finanziell
schaden auch emotional schaden weil hier
vieles weg ist so erbstücke und und
solche sachen wo wirklich das herz dran
hängen aber uns ist körperlich nichts
passiert und von daher ist alles halb so
schlimm und von daher kann man das auch
alles
versuchen positiv zu sehen den humor
nicht verlieren und einfach weitermachen
[Musik]